what spray body work Infiniti and today
we're back with another gun game this
time we have 21 different sports
equipments and after each point
sergeants will get harder let's go 0:04
spinner I think you didn't see that
coming okay time for the dot sport so
close you have a different tactic yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
disk with this rocket you should be able
to put the shots in
I'm not gonna do the skating intro like
oh hey looks too dangerous next up whoa
not those yet cricket match come on it
was like short put I'll go with this one
this feels like a bazooka yeah this is
becoming a real gonna game
[Music]
no it never gets rid of the stick
no probably not I think I'll take the
left hand a boxing club let's go okay
Rocky
[Music]
just have to play safe I made make off
bamboo that's how I will be yeah I'm
gonna play safe yeah finally I get rid
of this one that was a cure are you
trying to scare me with that yes no like
my bracket twiddling it didn't work
time for some squash how's my of course
technique the use of my chopping
exercises yeah that's looking good look
at that footwork Oh quite slick
[Music]
I have to say I like this this is my
favorite item so far five for the Boomer
right aha
oh you're shopping with that also hi
hands
apurate Amy like joke with everything no
I'm not gonna miss Mimi there just don't
feel long rally ah come on it's not the
heaviest but it's not the lightest 16
kilograms I so love a good workout yeah
I can't get that one a volleyball
yes yeah I knew that I know Joey I'm
taking you all to rate the technique
beginner mind of minus four minus or
plus plus
he's like I'm doing all the work here
okay this is this is for one it's like
I'm gonna win this this is how it feels
to be all four in table paints like you
just stand there and let the opponent do
all the work like this
[Music]
[Applause]
come on language begorrah
I think the officer all say that you
lose the point if you hit the copper so
I can get rid of this boxing back a bit
maybe this is the right tactic
[Music]
surprisingly good shots try as hard as I
could but Paul didn't really go anywhere
okay this is gonna be extremely
interesting
oh yeah it looks like I didn't even try
but there was like nothing you could do
like it so get rid of this I got it so
next up is this swimming ding what did
you say what okay I got it
[Applause]
yes yes I'm so really I'm not gonna miss
that again next up we have two yoga mats
oh nice I think the official will say
that you can't have the ball on the
racket for 15 seconds see I found it
yeah love it feels like normal for me to
play nice forgive me you fought well
next up for me at the roller we're gonna
try a new tactic
[Music]
the bike helmet I think I'm gonna ditch
the fruit tactic come on no no I really
need to think how to play with this good
child
oh no I'll go with this actually John is
like one yes
come on I really didn't know like what I
was thinking there I didn't throw it
that far but I'll take it
yeah
[Music]
for the hardcore shots it links up fight
for this keep oh yeah come on come on we
come on didn't work this time
you took it from me the dots
yeah this is my big chance to be the
senator yeah
sudden death that's better thank you
good luck there is still a lot of you
guys who haven't subscribed to our
channel also help assault and do it now
I'm select but this is yeah it's even
way harder than the pen